the five execs selling stock in the two
months leading up to the collapse is an
indication that they knew there was a
collapse coming which that deserves an
investigation in my opinion
Biden says they're all going to be fired
all the Management's going to be fired
and that
the people running the bank shouldn't
work there anymore those are his words
Joe Biden doesn't know what should
happen with a bank so the president is
in no position to make a call about what
should or should not happen with a bank
if you want to have investigations or
something fine but Joe Biden is in no
position to be making calls about a bank
at all I don't trust Joe Biden's calls
about basically anything the man is
barely con barely has contact with
reality so Joe Biden's opinion on Banks
and who should run a bank is the least
interesting thing in the world this
string of tweets that he wrote this
under on the uh on Friday the FDIC
threat obviously was not written by him